Let's do another quiz related to Amdahl's Law.
We still have our instruction types of integer,
branch, load, and store. Let's say now that
the percentage of execution time we spent on each
is 40% for integer, 20% on branches, 30% on loads, 10% on stores. And the CPI,
we get for then is one for integer,
four branches, two for loads, and three for stores.
We have a processor that is clocked at two GHz. Let's say we are considering the
possible improvements that are reducing the branch CPI
from four to three. Increase the clock frequency
of the processor from two GHz to two point three GHz. And reducing the store CPI
from three to two. Assuming we can only do one of these, which would you choose
according to the overall speed?